[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de dimanche en politique les
rebondissements de la sphère vincent
lambert encore cette semaine ont remis
sur le devant de la scène médiatique la
question de la fin de vie au coeur d'une
famille qui se déchire son histoire est
devenue au fil des ans l'objet d'un
combat politique et soulève de
nombreuses questions notamment sur le
rôle que peuvent avoir les proches et
les médecins dans un pays où la loi
claisse leonetti a instauré un droit à
la sédation profonde et continue mais
pas à l'euthanasie active ou au suicide
assisté contrairement à d'autres pays
européens on se questionne ce matin la
sphère vincent lambert est elle
révélatrice d'une faille dans la loi que
l'ess leonetti ces questions si intime
doivent-elles et peuvent-elles être régi
par la loi
faut-il revoir la législation française
sur la fin de vie on en débat avec nos
invités en direct ce dimanche serge
bacherot bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
délégué de l'adn des en côte d'or la dmd
c'est l'association pour le droit à
mourir dans la dignité
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
malgré vous cette affaire vincent
lambert vous aide à remettre sur le
devant de la scène
votre demande qui est celle du droit à
mourir dans la dignité tout à fait
depuis 1980 la dmd militent pour qu'on
ait enfin en france cette loi de liberté
dont vous avez parlé qui permette
l'euthanasie active ou le suicide
assisté bien évidemment dans des
conditions très réglementée très
précises on va y revenir mais cette
affaire vincent lambert elle elle vient
appuyer finalement ce que vous demandez
depuis les années 80 malheureusement oui
malheureusement oui c'est vrai qu'il
faut des événements comme ça pour que la
question soit reposée d'une façon d'une
façon formelle
si vincent lambert par exemple avait
rempli ses directives anticipées
on ne connaîtrait personne personne que
les traits vincent lambert on va y
revenir dans un instant dominique
barrière bonjour bonjour vous êtes la
présidente de jalmalv dijon jalmalv
c'est une fédération d'associations et
ça veut dire jusqu'à la mort accompagner
la vie vos bénévoles interviennent
notamment en service de soins palliatifs
cette affaire vincent lambert quel
regard vous portez dessus aujourd'hui et
qu'est ce qu'elle nous dit finalement de
notre société alors comme bénévole on
n'a pas nous à se prononcer sur
la sphère vincent lambert en soi par
contre ce qu elle ce qu'elle met
vraiment en lumière c'est que dans le
fond on est tous en interaction les uns
avec les autres
derrière ce que vous appelez la faire un
sens inverse il ya un homme mince aux
lombaires qui avait certainement pas
prévu une destinée pareil il y à des
proches qui se déchire qui se
déchiraient avant et qui c'est pas parce
qu'une une situation est délicate comme
ça que ça ne continue pas c'est la vie
la vie continue comme ça mais pour
autant on voit l'impact que cela peut
avoir que toute décision médicale peut
avoir sur les proches et ça je trouve
que l'ego de l'homme là se trouve bien
bien entamée si quelque chose que vous
ressentez dans les services les malades
et les familles que vous accompagnez
vous voyez cette question qui revient
quelle que soit la situation
nous accompagnons non seulement les
personnes qui sont gravement malades ou
en fin de vie
mon deuil on accompagne tous les proches
et donc on a cette expérience et ce
regard de l'impact que cela peut avoir
et avec tous les degrés en fonction des
situations de vie des situations
familiales et des relations c'est
vraiment l'homme n'est pas n'est pas
seul l'homme est un maillon d'une chaîne
et
il a pilé dans une lignée et on voit une
différence d'appréciation déjà avec
votre collègue bénévoles en face de vous
alors que le point de départ de vos
associations pouvaient être le même le
point de départ c'est c'est la
souffrance qui était engendré la douleur
et la souffrance qui était engendrer
lorsque la médecine n'a pas su soigner
guérir c'était l'époque du sida c'était
l'époque des maladies cancéreuses
terrible et donc voilà nous certains
militent pour on va dire provoqué la
mort de ces personnes et nous vous pour
éviter les souffrances pour éviter les
souffrances d'accord avec l'essentiel de
ce que vous dites bien évidemment par
contre ce n'est pas provoquer la mort
c'est la personne qui doit lentilles
ciel si elles l'estiment que sa vie
devient tellement et digne impossible
qu'elle ait ce droit là pour moi c'est
une loi de liberté
on va vous d'accord avec vous sauf sur
ce point car on va y venir bien sûr dans
un tout petit instant sébastien mirek
bonjour bonjour vous êtes référent de la
république en marche en côte d'or vous
est également médecin de profession
ça va évidemment revenir sur le tapis au
moment de la révision des lois de
bioéthique cette question de la fin de
vie éventuellement de l'euthanasie et du
suicide assisté et c'est la majorité
présidentielle il est prête
alors je suis médecin anesthésiste
réanimateur et donc le travail tous les
jours dans un service de réanimation et
je suis aussi membre du comité
réanimation notre société savante au
niveau national lasfar donc et donc on a
un avis sur ce sûr c'est sur la fin de
vie on travaille tous les jours non pas
un point ça pour ce qui est de la
majorité présidentielle que je
représente en tant que référent la
république en marche côte d'or
je ne vais pas commenter les décisions
et les rebondissements les
rebondissements les rangs dernière au
brouillard rebondissements qui vient du
gouvernement lui même pas plus tard que
cette semaine c'est à dire un pourvoi en
cassation sur sur la dernière décision
qui a été pris ça veut donc dire que le
président la république qui ne voulait
pas s'en mêler à une époque a finalement
décidé de s'en mêler
alors résumons je ne vais pas commenter
ces recours parce qu'il ya effectivement
des
ddd juridiction qui sont en train
d'analyser l'ensemble du dossier
il faut prendre ce sujet avec beaucoup
d'humilité beaucoup d'humanité avec le
moins de dogme possible l'éthique
médicale
c'est quoi c'est l'autonomie du patient
c'est la bienveillance et c'est là non
malveillance et dans notre code de
déontologie notamment on à l'article 38
qui parlent que nous ne pouvons pas
donner délibérément la mort et on a une
loi claisse leonetti on va y revenir je
pense ensuite pour pouvoir échanger
notamment sur les directives anticipées
sur la personne de confiance sur les
soins palliatifs nous devrons développer
et sur l'information de nos concitoyens
et du monde médical
alors on va y revenir dans un instant qu
ici on voulait bonjour vous êtes diacres
du diocèse d'hôtes amour présents ou
représentés donc l'église catholique
dans ce débat par ailleurs vous êtes
aussi médecin c'est important de le
souligner dans cette affaire lambert on
voit bien qu'il ya une dimension
religieuse qui existent aussi notamment
pour une partie de la famille qu'est-ce
que ça évoque pour vous déjà je pourrais
dire que on a quand même bien oublier
monsieur vincent lambert la personne de
vincent lambert
on en a fait un cas on c'est vrai que
quand on a en a cp on parle de k1 de cas
singulier mais ce qu'a finalement est
devenue une affaire est maintenant une
cause une cause à défendre
est-ce qu on est pour ou contre l'arrêt
de ce traitement est ce que ce sont des
traitements ou pas on pourra reparler
après est-ce qu'on va donner la mort à
monsieur vincent lambert est ce qu'on va
parler d'euthanasie ou de ses pas
vraiment son comme il n'est pas en fin
de vie pour moi au sens strict il est
pas en fin de vie et le problème est de
savoir qui l'accompagné à l'accompagner
est ce qu'il devrait être
toujours dans ce même service et qu'il
aurait changé de service voilà alors
quand on se dit qu'on a oublié vincent
lambert vincent lambert est une personne
et comme chaque personne et l'a1 vie
âge et ce visage va nous obliger nous
oblige respect au respect de cette
personne de sa dignité
cette dignité qui ce qui ne se décrète
pas qui est inhérente à la personne
un prince est à la personne il n'y a pas
d' appareils pour mesurer la dignité
bien c'est bien de dignité dont il est
question et 11,6 du côté de la dmd ski
parce qu'il veut dire qu'on peut vouloir
la dignité de la personne avec des
projets différents
moi je ne veux pas là ni dignité de la
personne je veux que la personne choisie
ce sa dignité
ce que moi c'est la décision de la
personne malheureusement pour vincent
lambert il n'a rien pu dire et
maintenant en effet les gens se
déchirent sur son cas mais la dignité
c'est pour moi c'est une affaire
personnelle
alors je vous propose de dire revenir
dans un tout petit un stand d'abord si
je termine l'amour mais où est donc la
dignité dont effectivement ne se décrète
pas et il faut prendre soin de monsieur
vincent lambert
il faut prendre soin et effectivement
l'accompagner jusqu'au bout peut-être
dans un autre service
alors je vais je vais vous proposer de
faire un point tout de suite sur cette
fameuse loi claisse leonetti dont la
ministre de la santé disait il ya
quelques mois qu'elle était finalement
mal connues méconnues par les français
et toutes les possibilités qu'elle offre
dans le cadre de la fin de vie les
principales règles résumé tout de suite
par daniel sportiello la loi sur la fin
de vie a été porté par les députés jean
leonetti et alain claeys l'un de droite
l'autre de gauche
notre proposition cloud amis chers
collègues part du plus près de la
demande de nos concitoyens celle d'avoir
une femme vit sans souffrance et de
pouvoir la maîtriser jusqu'au bout
la loi sur la fin de vie n'autorise ni
l'euthanasie ni le suicide assisté
mais dom de nouveaux droits aux malades
incurables qui refusent l'acharnement
thérapeutique comme le droit à une
sédation profonde et continue jusqu'au
décès le but de la sédation profonde en
phase terminale
c'est de soulager une souffrance le but
de l'euthanasie c'est de donner la mort
à un malade
la sédation qu'est ce que c'est d'autre
qu'une anesthésie profonde
le patient qui en a fait la demande par
des directives anticipées qui sont
désormais contraignante et plonger
lorsqu'ils souffrent trop dans un
sommeil dont il ne se réveillera pas
sous réserve de sa volonté
les traitements seront suspendus en cas
d'accident si le patient ne peut plus
exprimer ses volontés une personne de
confiance qu'il aura désigné s'en
chargera pour lui on voit bien que le
député léonetti lui-même fait fait la
nuance évidemment entre sédation
profonde état nazi ou suicide assisté
dominique barrière est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette vision de la loi
léonetti c'est à dire la sédation
profonde en général et on le disait dans
le sujet et irréversible de toute façon
alors nous nous sommes engagés depuis
2012 dans la la perspective de faire
connaître la loi et de montrer jusqu'où
va la loire et et nous avons un grand
bourgogne on doit en être à 80 débat à
peu près depuis 2012 et on fait un
constat unanime c'est que personne ne
connaît la loi
et lorsque on va auprès du grand public
ou dans des ehpad
lorsqu'on rencontre les familles jean
marc ayrault et jean parce que les
directives anticipées n'existe pas mais
les gens ne savent même pas qu'ils ont
la possibilité et le droit depuis 1999
d'arrêter un traitement depuis 2002
d'être informé vous vous dites les gens
ne savent pas jusqu'où va la loi oui ça
veut dire que pour vous la loi
aujourd'hui telle qu'elle est faite elle
va assez loin
bien entendu mais encore faudrait-il
qu'on la clique et que et que qui dit
droit des malades dit que nous avons la
possibilité de les faire respecter est
je pense que quand on montre toutes les
possibilités de la loi quand on explique
tout cela est bien très sincèrement on
n'a pas beaucoup d'autres
questionnements
c'est pas le cas de serre va se battre
ou et de la dmd vous estimez que cette
loi claisse leonetti si elle a permis
des avancées aujourd'hui elle ne suffit
plus exactement elle apporter de la vie
de pdi de grandes avancées par contre
elle est un conte il anticipé notamment
voilà les directives anticipées le nom
le nom oui c'est pas enfin on va par an
oui oui mais ça a été sonné inscrit dans
la loi c-10 confirme confiant mais
amplifié en fait deux mois du film
maintenant elle s'impose aux médecins
oui d'accord ok oui cette loi leonetti
elle a été fait a été une avancée
incontestable n'y avait rien du tout
bien évidemment mais elle assure les par
exemple l'acharnement thérapeutique
elle empêche l'acharnement thérapeutique
malheureusement en france il y a encore
des situations d'acharnement
thérapeutique et comme vous l'avez dit
eh bien en effet la loi n'est pas
appliquée dans nombreux cas nous ce
qu'on souhaite c'est ajouter ça que
quelqu'un je suis d'accord avec leur s
sauf ça je dois pouvoir
personnellement si j'arrive dans une
situation absolument impossible bien
encadrée par la loi
pourquoi actuellement il y a on recense
plus de 4500 cars 2 tan asie clandestine
en france a accompli attendait les
chiffres de l'ined qui sont contestées
oui tout à fait c'est complètement petit
peut-être que c'est un coach yves
desbrosses est prête à caution il n'y a
jamais eu des milliers ça c'est certain
j'en connais personnellement
quelques-uns des pv mais ça y est les
gens qui prient serge méresse et
également pardon dans les deux venant
mais ça se passe dans l'est dans les
pays qui ont dépénalisé et on n'avait
dépénalisé parce qu'il y avait autant
édictant destine et l'euthanasie
clandestine n'a pas diminué et existe
toujours
alors comme liv et g nous ce qu'on
souhaite c'est avant les vg se faisait
maintenant elle conduite se faire la
différence qu'avant elle se faisait une
façon clandestine dans très mauvaises
conditions les médecins pourraient en
témoigner
maintenant libéré quelque chose de
cadres et qui se fait dans de bonnes
conditions on souhaite
que la loi lui la nouvelle loi qui soit
justement pas la loi leonetti en
conservant quelques avancées permettent
plusieurs choses premièrement que
l'acharnement thérapeutique soit
absolument une impossibilité et que
rapidement première chose si les gens le
souhaitent
d'accord parce qu'il faut qu'on revienne
sur cette notion d' acharnement
thérapeutique d'accord et puis la
deuxième est essentielle c'est qu'en
effet que quelqu'un qui souhaite parce
qu'il est arrivé dans une situation
impossible à vivre et où c'est plus une
survie qu'une vie ils puissent comme en
belgique comme en suisse dans de bonnes
conditions tranquille et bien mettre fin
à sa vie grâce à l'euthanasie au sud à
sébastien mirek on a beaucoup critiqué
cette loi classe leonetti en disant
finalement c'était une loi plus pour les
médecins que pour les malades parce que
de fait elle offrait un cadre aux
médecins qui savait du coup où aller
n'empêche que l'acharnement
thérapeutique qui commence où il
s'arrête ou alors est ce que vous
arrivez à justement je vais je vais le
spécifier cette loi la première loi
léonetti elel son évolution la loi
claisse leonetti ne parle pas
d'acharnement thérapeutique mais parle
d'un refus de l'obstination
déraisonnable qui veut bien dire que en
fait des traitements qui avait été mis
en place ne sont plus on va dire sont
devenus disproportionnés ne sont plus
adaptées pour le maintien de la vie
artificielle
donc ça c'est extrêmement important elle
ne parle absolument pas d'acharnement
thérapeutique
cette loi a été faite pour les droits
des patients en fin de vie
elle n'a pas été fait pour les médecins
elle remet le patient au sens bien deux
dispositifs au centre pour que le
patient puisse donner ses volontés à la
fois par la directive anticipée qui ont
évolué avec des directives anticipées
on va dire contraignante que le médecin
que chaque médecin doit aller chercher
avant toute décision
sauf deux cas qui sont les urgences
vitales et si les directives anticipées
sont jugés inappropriés ou non conformes
avec des quatre extrêmement précis et on
voit que la loi est là deux ans et nous
cette loi modifié à deux ans malgré tout
il ya 40% des gens qui ont entendu
parler des des français pardon qui ont
entendu parler de ces directives
anticipées et seulement 13% qu'ils les
ont faites donc on voit bien qu'il ya
une difficulté à faire passer ce message
2 il faut en parler c'est pas parce que
qu'on parle de la fin de vie quand on
est en bonne santé qui ne faut pas qu'il
faut pas le rédiger et on parlait tout
le monde semble d'accord autour de la
table cette loi est mal connue avec par
contre à votre gauche on vous dit il
faut aller plus loin il faut passer à
autre chose alors je vais je vais
proposer à au docteur moulay de prendre
la parole parce que finalement vous ce
que vous craignez aussi à travers les
évolutions demandées par exemple par la
dmd c'est les dérives c'est les excès
c'est à dire à partir du moment où il ya
suicide assisté au tas nazis à quel
moment on estime que effectivement
c'était souhaitable ou pas tout à fait
alors déjà première chose qu'il faut
préciser c'est que l'église
effectivement n'est pas pour l'achat
d'un bunker thérapeutique au contraire
elles luttent contre l'acharnement
thérapeutique
elle est pour l'accompagnement
l'accompagnement des personnes jusqu'au
bout pour prendre soin de la personne
dans sa globalité pour la douleur
physique la douleur psychique et la
doller spirituel qu'on attend dans
souvent oubliée donc il faut prendre la
personne dans sa globalité et
l'accompagner jusqu'au bout premièrement
deuxièmement si on veut si on parle de
suicide assisté ou de l'euthanasie est
ce qu'on va réellement résoudre le
problème est ce qu'on va pas dépasser
déplacer le problème
et pourquoi tout simplement parce que
est ce que vous pensez pourvoir vous
vous assumez le droit de pouvoir faire
mourir une personne non mais alors qui
c'est qui va alors qui se fait dans
l'esprit et d'opinion on dit aussi que
finalement si ça existait très peu
d'ailleurs dans les autres pays c'est
assez marginale du coup mais pourquoi
l'inscrire dans la loi on y at il
vraiment besoin de ça et louis-pierre
sur cette lancée c'est le médecin qui va
être obligé de coucher la seringue
est ce que c'est une personne
responsabilité que les données et puis
même si un comité de sages et c'est pas
moi qui le dit c'est monsieur badinter
s'il vous plaît monsieur jean-pierre
agit comme un comité de sages ne peut
pas s'arroger le droit de faire mourir
une personne mais cette personne va
mourir simplement donc dans les temps
proches dans des souffrances
insupportables
si cette personne ne souhaite pas vivre
ce temps là elle le décide à condition
que les choses soient bien encadrés vous
l'avez dit c'est que dans les pays où ça
existe
attendez il ya pas plus de cas de au
contraire je vais terminer là dessus
pour moi ça me paraît important en
belgique
beaucoup de témoignages de deux belges
qu'ils ont ré prend plus lors des rites
et d'anticiper intégrant la possibilité
d'avoir l'euthanasie vivent mieux parce
qu'ils sont tranquilles beaucoup se font
opérer alors qu'ils le feraient pas
parce qu'il se dit si jamais j'arrive et
à une situation insupportable
l'euthanasie ce pourrait être ici
dominique barrières grillagées
nous on a une expérience quand même
d'accompagnement et moi je j'ai beaucoup
de respect pour toutes ces personnes qui
sont malades et qui n'ont non mais ça va
au delà de ça qui j'entends très souvent
c'est comme ça c'est à dire que l'ol en
iations une une résignation ou une
acceptation tout du moins unis matériaux
risation et c'est là où quand on voit là
je veux mourir dans la dignité je veux
vivre dans la dignité on est tous
d'accord n'était je veux pas souffrir si
possible et je ne veux pas souffrir ça
c'est on est tous d'accord là dessus
il n'empêche que on n'est pas
responsable et d'une maladie ou du grand
âge et pour autant il ya tout un travail
personnel et on constate que
véritablement l'homme a en lui des des
capacités mais insoupçonnées et et se
tend justement que vous
il se bat pas raccourcir que vous jouez
la cour sur 6,6 sur ce temps de deux
revers de vie accompagnée non mais je ce
temps de vie accompagnent fait un
raccourci un peu non j'ai entendu
puisque c'est souvent ceux et celles en
soit je ne souhaite pas mes souffrances
vie ne vaut pas la peine d'être vécue
moi oui c'est vous qui le dites
la mairesse pas la dignité aux gens
c'est vous qui dit décrété qu'une des
écoutes personnes et dean ou indignes de
vivre la mienne utilité monsieur dans
mon assiette
je parle pas de votre dignité chacun a
la sienne mais il avait un cassoulet du
personnel et dignité qui est un très sec
qui fait partie de sa personne elle même
oui mais c'est vrai que quand on meurt
dans d'atroces souffrances non à la
rémoise lagaf' a même posé on a comme
oui on a quand même des moyens
effectivement de calmer les douleurs et
donc la sédation maintenant que tu
existes continue profonde jusqu'à la
mort effectivement ce n'est pas de
l'état nazi
c'est décidé d'arrêter les souffrances
avec l'accord de la famille avec un
consensus de l'équipe de soins et à
partir de là on se dit l'acharnement
stop et va permettre à cette personne de
partir tranquillement près l'entouraient
et éventuellement de pouvoir encore
parlé à ça alors c'est par sa famille je
vais vous proposer de regarder les
résultats de ce sondage ipsos qui a été
réalisé en 2010 est pour le quotidien la
croix
89% des français et 72 % des catholiques
pratiquants se disaient favorables au
suicide assisté ou à l'euthanasie alors
première question pour sébastien y est
ce que quand l'opinion publique et si
massivement pour l'évolution de la loi
est ce que ça veut dire que bien
emmanuel macron et de sa majorité vont
le prendre en compte dans les prochaines
évolutions dans les prochains mois voilà
je vais parler au nom de
médecin que je suis le médecin
animateurs parce que oui et citoyens
aussi on voit bien qu'il ya un défaut de
communication et d'information des
citoyens et ce sondage si on va un peu
plus loin dans le temps les raisons du
sondage et si on explique les choses à
la fois avec l'accompagnement que vous
avez on a tous évoqué l'accompagnement
et le droit on est tous égaux en statue
on est tous égaux en statue qu'on soit
médecin citoyens patients avant d'être
malade nous sommes des citoyens
donc ça c'est extrêmement important et
quand on regarde ces sons d'un ce
sondage déjà peut-être expliquons la loi
ce qu'on est en train de faire la queue
sans vous pensez que les gens qui
répondent aux sondages qui n'ont pas
conscience de ce qui existe déjà et je
pense qu'un certain lampard leur en
parlant des soins palliatifs en parlant
des directives anticipées de la personne
de confiance qui est maintenant demandé
avant chaque hospitalisation et en
expliquant que gouverneur vient or même
en fait c'est ce qu' il y aurait plus
besoin de ta nazim suicide assisté si
tout le monde avait bien compris n'est
pas un cadeau qu'on réponde et puis
c'est toujours ça ne peut être qu'une
situation exceptionnelle mais qui
devrait être possible si en effet je
suis personnellement c'est bien de
parler de parler de soi je suis dans une
situation en effet je suis en soins
palliatifs façon et je souffre je vais
pas demander de tête par contre je veux
conserver cette possibilité si en effet
il y avait en france suffisamment de
lits alors une autre un autre problème
il y avait je pense que vous n'allez pas
le contester
y a que 25 20 25 % de personnes qui ont
besoin des fat soins palliatifs qui
peuvent en bénéficier
nous on revendique aussi que tout
l'aspect santé mais en amour je suis
très satisfait mais il y a trente ans de
ça il n'y avait pas de soins palliatifs
donc regardons déjà le positif
soyons positifs et optimistes et au
contraire développons ça et arrêtons si
on veut parler véritablement de soins
palliatifs
osons les soins palliatifs ne nous
cachons pas derrière le petit doigt en
parlant de soins de support qui ne sont
que des soins palliatifs masqué qu'on
fait dès le début mais on
non ce pas parce qu'elle soins
palliatifs dans veut dire dans
l'imaginaire populaire ccc la mort c'est
la porte d'entrée
mais mes leçons palliatifs s'est pas
senti face à celle annoncée s'est vidé
que les gens question voulait un mot un
mot quand même je vais pas vous empêcher
de parler des soins palliatifs mais le
deuxième chiffres du sondage c'est 72 %
des catholiques pratiquants se déclarent
favorables à l'euthanasie et au suicide
assisté alors ce chiffre m'a surpris
donc je vous le cache pas mais peut-être
mais c'est peut-être aussi que même les
catholiques ne sont pas au courant
complètement de ce doux toute l'étendue
de la loi tout que les possibilités de
ses possibilités et donc cette loi
devrait déjà expliqué en premier lieu
déjà aux médecins aux soignants wii qui
a donné l'information à la famille aux
manades est allé aux patients et aux
publics à tout le monde que tout le
monde soit bien au courant de cette fois
des possibilités de cette loi et puis je
vais même aller plus loin c'est une
culture des soins palliatifs qu'il
faudrait développer et je pense que le
gouvernement a un rôle à jouer il nous
reste une minute servent à chaud j'ai
compris que pour vous il faut quand même
revoir cette loi est allé plus loin
faut aller plus loin parce que je suis
d'accord avec tout ce que vous dites les
soins palette il faut aujourd'hui c'est
une revendication que tout le monde y
ait accès et que ce soit qu'on meurt
dans la dignité jusqu'au bout mais on
veut absolument avoir ses possibilités
déjà au bout on vivra dans la dignité
jusqu'au bout oui merci beaucoup
bien évidemment il ya toujours merci
beaucoup de m'avoir vous en doutez 1
mais que ma fin de vie soit en effet si
simplement la personne le souhaite ce
swap aussi c'est facile mais qu'il faut
revoir la loi où il faut simplement
mieux l'expliquer
mon sens il faut mieux l'expliquer il
faut retravailler ces points-là et
trouver l'équilibré le médecin de
retrouver l'équilibré entre le curatif
et le palliatif herring barrière il faut
amplifier amplifié tous les efforts
qu'on fait
et accentuer nous avons tous une
responsabilité les uns vers les autres
on a fini bon d'accord c'est dire qu'il
faut amplifier et parler de culture de
faire ces actifs
merci à tous les cadres d'avoir accepté
de répondre à ces questions et de
débattre merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis dans un instant un point sur
l'actualité régionale avec emmanuel
pinsonneault suivi de la partie
nationale de dimanche en politique
francis letellier reçoit amélie de
montchalin secrétaire d'état aux
affaires étrangères bon dimanche